right as we continue joining us now with
reaction to all these scandals
surrounding Hillary Clinton the
Democratic Party including yeah
Russian lies to impact on all on
election the author of this book is
amazing billionaire at the barricades
and I assume maybe and I think the years
2020 she will be the host of a brand-new
Fox News show the Ingraham angle which
start Monday
oh I know you're number one on the New
York bestseller listing and I know
you're doing great here's the problem
we're waiting when do we get the
Ingraham angle we're just kidding we're
doing the angle on the pencils in my
office across the hall the staplers just
as soon as the stapler gets firing like
you know pencil darts at my hand I don't
know as if I don't have enough enemies
thank you very much we're good I just
can't get over how they used Russian
lies with fusion GPS to influence the
election and how everybody now has gone
silent on Russia now that they know and
we've been saying this is going to
boomerang back never mind they knew
Putin had infiltrated the country and
everybody had knowledge of it FBI had it
Eric Holder had it the president
probably had it Obama and is that
presidential daily briefings I cannot
believe the degree of lying hypocrisy
and frankly they put this country
country in danger when you think about
it Sean going back to the 90s I had like
a flashback of all the dirty politicking
and the dirty campaigning and the use of
private investigators the Clintons
utilized back in the 90s remember the
name Terry lens nur he was a guy who was
like going through people's garbage this
is what she plays yeah this is what they
do this is what they've always done and
now they've taken it to an international
intrigue degree with involving the
former Soviet Union and when you have a
Kremlin written dossier that is compiled
by the Christopher Steele fellow and he
puts it all together but all the dirty
lurid fake details are provided by
rusha the idea that the highest level of
the Clinton campaign and perhaps even
Hillary herself didn't know about its
provenance didn't know where it came
from that just that just doesn't pass
the straight-faced test I mean we I
guess we have to hear from mrs. Clinton
I want it I want a real interview with
her not an interview with a favorable
journalist but she should come on and
talk to a serious journalist about what
she knew that's in the ride that's
preceded this way well she's afraid yeah
well of course and then she's
compromised I mean she was lashing out
it may be and by name fox news channel
by name just this week what about this
uranium one I want to get your take on
uranium one but I think circumstances
with any smart person ever give Vladimir
20% of our uranium yeah and then and
then you look at they knew he had
Russian operatives in the country and
that that was that was their gold the
corner of the market and they had an
informant inside telling them about
everything they're doing bribery
kickbacks extortion all this how could
this possibly happen all of that that
you just said Sean and then add the fact
that we have this committee on foreign
investments the Sofia stored which
includes pretty much the entire cabinet
of the Obama administration obviously
Hillary sits on it and the Department of
Justice Secretary of Secretary of State
they all sit on this committee now you
can pull a great ten people can right
across the street at Union Station the
train station in Washington who don't
know anything about politics but if you
ask them okay we could approve or
disapprove of Russia getting 20% of our
uranium that could be used for nuclear
weapons nuclear power deed that's a good
idea
I've got ten out of ten maybe nine if
you can consider a drunk guy on the
street Scarborough so you dances so all
right so but what you have here is they
knew Vladimir Putin had infiltrated the
country had spies in the country was
doing illegal activities in the country
and that's top of them never being smart
enough not to do whatever but they all
approved it anyway and then the money
comes back
I don't understand like I can usually at
least understand liberal logic there's
nothing here that makes any sense
except that they sold out the country a
massive appeasement mentality and that
they're corrupt well it's it's it's
corrupt to the core it's perhaps other
financial interests that we don't know
about I think there's a lot that we just
don't know I think there are a lot of
pieces to this puzzle Shawn that we
still don't know we did not have a
Justice Department but that really
wanted to be transparent and the way
they handled this this case this case
that it has many different aspects to it
they didn't want they didn't want an
informant to testify to Congress there
was no real congressional oversight of
this deal again on its face it's
ludicrous that we ever would have
approved this just on its face but the
fact that they're accusing Trump of
collusion when all this was happening
that that is what truly makes I think
Americans who are tuned into this really
sick well congrats on the book
billionaires of the barricades New York
Times bestseller
are you really showing up to work Monday
or is this all one big joke because I've
never seen anybody sign a contract and
never show up to work you never show up
to work what does that mean maybe the
week after we're just I'm just doing a
very Zen approach to my Fox show it's
just guys to breathing after to get in
for it you're like O'Reilly but O'Reilly
took off and buddy it worked here 20
years you're taking as many days off as
him I'm working hard across the hall on
my desk okay so we're gonna really see
you Monday your prime day and are you
gonna pass are we gonna pass like I've
got a pet drink I'm gonna say Oh
chair she didn't show up Hannity has an
extra hand me something killed NATO fill
in because kill needs on every other
hour of the day so alright the Ingraham
angle starts Monday